[Music]
whatever i'm doing in that moment
i really try to be completely focused
and present on that moment and never
thinking about the thing that comes next
and over time i think i train myself to
be able to do that so
you know if i get up in the morning and
walk my daughter to the bus she's more
than old enough that she does not need
me to walk her to the bus she's maybe
even a little embarrassed by it but i
have this theory that if you're there as
a parent
sometimes in the middle of the routine
like a meaningful moment will happen and
it might not happen most days when it's
you know seven in the morning we're
bleary-eyed and neither of us is in the
greatest mood but if we're both there
you know one out of 10 days or even if
it's one out of 100 days something will
happen and i really try to just be
present for that
if i sit down in front of my computer
and say okay i'm going to write a column
now
i literally shut out everything
except for that column
and
i turn on my voice recognition software
because i do everything by voice
recognition software
and i
just focus completely and i've trained
myself to just put myself into flow
and i do it i don't worry about whether
it's good or it's bad
i just get it out there i'll worry about
whether it's bad when i'm done with it
and then it's done and then i stop take
a deep breath read it over i hit send to
my editor thank god i have an editor so
that i'm not reliant on myself to know
whether it was any good or not an editor
will tell you this one was terrible
throw this one out
but i send it to the editor and i put it
out of my mind completely it's gone
and then i do the next thing
and
by doing it that way i think i'm just
saving the time waste that we have
in
a kind of
self-questioning that inevitably
sinks in the rest of the time now you
might say what's missing from this is
self-reflection and honestly i think for
many years of my life that's true i
think for many years of my life i was
missing genuine self-reflection like i
had i had fake self-reflection where i
had conversations and thought about
things but i wasn't really really really
doing it
and it was until my late thirties when
um i went to see a shrink for the first
time because i was having a you know a
kind of little early you know early
mid-life meltdown
that i
actually engaged in that kind of
self-reflection and i did not know how
to do it i really didn't know how to do
it and i would say to myself after
therapy oh my god i'm failing at therapy
like i know i just wasted that whole
session and i kept on saying that for a
long time
what do you mean by failed
what does failing look like how how
how does one fail at that
well i guess the reason i thought i was
failing is i was mistakenly thinking
that therapy was like every other thing
that i do you know a concentrated 45
minute session where you're supposed to
accomplish something and i would go in
and on the way out i was like i didn't
accomplish anything i don't feel better
i don't feel worse i didn't have any
deep self revelation like what the hell
did i do
you know i was and in the sense that i
was only doing it wrong because i
thought i was doing it wrong like you
can't do therapy wrong but i thought
that there was a way to do it right and
therefore there must be a way that i
wasn't doing it and also i wasn't
getting any better so then i thought
okay you know i really am doing it wrong
and then over time took a long time i
came to realize that just sitting there
and being in the moment and letting it
happen and not
saying okay i'm going to go in to
achieve this and i'm going to leave
having achieved that was the only way
therapy was ever going to do anything
and i wish i could tell you that like i
thought of that quickly but i didn't
so for sake of clarity
you
ended up viewing
therapy as a almost a meditative
time for non-accomplishment through
which you found it therapeutically
valuable yeah i think that's it i mean i
think it's that i don't know about
meditative because you are
talking
you know
and depending on who your therapist is
the therapist might also be talking
because some don't like to say very much
but
i think what i realized was that you
have to just let things bubble up you
can't force it
you cannot force your way into having
successful
talk therapy
and that was the takeaway from me and i
know most people listening to this are
like uh duh like you have to be pretty
dumb not to have realized that like it
says it on the bottle you know but i i
was that kind of dumb and i think it
derived from
you know having this approach to
everything else where i thought okay
what am i gonna do what am i supposed to
be doing here i'm going to totally do it
and i'm going to do it in a total
concentrated way and i'm going to know
at the end of it that i accomplished it
so that i can move on to the next thing
you